you think as women we're honest to each
other
i don't completely think so either yeah
women aren't friends with each other
what about you um yeah i would partially
agree to it yeah no that we're not
honest to eat with each other yeah
i don't think women like each other to
be honest yeah i would say that i don't
personally i mean not everyone but yeah
big just do you like me
no
of course i do
i mean like obviously there's there's a
handful yeah there's a handful that that
like each other but in terms of like in
terms of like the competition the
competition market
yeah girls will will fight over a guy
yeah yeah even if you're friends with
sounds so bad
ask yourself this question
out of all the for the females or the
people of people that you call friends
how many of them you've spoken about
behind their back
oh shoot
[Laughter]
guys if i say something about behind one
of my boys back it's something that i
have or will say to his face but ask
yourself again be honest like how many
times have you talked about that person
you call your friend yeah but the thing
is girls are more emotional what i'm
saying so like i feel like girls do it
in the form of like venting and then
they get it out and then like we come
back down to earth and we're like okay
that's rational enough to like bring it
up to her we're men i i think men are
just more like rooted in logic yeah but
then if you find out that your emotional
friends said x y and z about you when
she was
co-venting yeah
but i don't know i feel like as girls
like you kind of know like your friends
are going to talk about you a little bit
yeah
that way and i i just don't get mad
because i'm like okay if she's venting
and then
if it's a big enough problem they'll
bring it to you
i don't know if you guys feel the same
way but
no i do go ahead for me
when i do vent the only person i've been
to is my brother because i know that
he's a guy he's not going to go say
anything but
i i analyze when females vent to me i'm
like if you're going to say that about
that person you say that's your best
friend you say
dasha road dog
then what are you saying about me and
and it no just how i am and like the
relationship with them
no i think the same thing like
especially if they're like yeah she told
me not to tell anyone this but i'm
telling you i'm like
that line that is the last
time
i share anything ever
[Music]
well for me it's because when i was in
sixth form um
well i i became really good friends with
this goal um we became best friends
we're still best friends to this day so
um having a female best friend which is
i advocate for everyone to have a really
close friend from the opposite sex
because it benefits you in more ways
than one right so you think that one
hundred percent i don't i got to i got
yeah i think men and women can't be
friends but it's down to how mature you
are as individuals do you find so she if
she tried to sleep with you would you
say no yeah i mean
i'm in a relationship right now so
obviously that's not no but did you find
her
yeah so
so if you wasn't in a relationship
you'll sleep with her
i think personally right from from
having a
we've been so close with so long that i
now
see you as a sister that's regardless
bro if she tried it on you would you
give it to me maybe
let me first be we're friends sure no no
i think it's easier me
she okay okay okay you're alone she
walks in naked you're not
you're you're
you're gonna say no no you're gonna
try it see next time you'll hang out try
it i'm kidding
i'm playing i think it's gonna because
the thing is like like i said it's down
to the the individuals themselves right
it's not it's it's like it's one of
those things where like i can't make a
blanket statement or oatmeal and it
could be friends with all females
because it's not true it depends on the
female it depends on the male me and my
friend have got to a point where we now
see each other as just family members
rather than friends so i think for us
personally just for our situation which
i know we hate doing we're talking about
niche situations in the grand scheme but
like
it really comes down to how you guys
communicate with each other um and like
yeah because the thing is she knows that
i fancy that when we when we first
started
you know i think like my opinion on your
situation it's a
you've got to apply it with that gold
where you know you don't want to ruin
the friendship yeah and but i think if
there was
she gave you some sort of hall pass
where you don't ruin the friendship
but you can still hit i think you'll
take that bro but isn't maturity knowing
when to do things and when not to do
things is your girlfriend watching yeah
okay
i'm not worried about it
but yeah i really do generally think
that it's really a thing where like
it's it's an individual bit because not
everyone's going there right now i agree
with that i think
what i would say is is there a
possibility that
in that dynamic of your friendship with
that female
the roles changed and where it was once
upon a time you liked her the fact that
you're still friends and you're now in a
relationship maybe she likes you
and that's what's holding that
friendship
together no
no next time if you guys ever invite me
on i'll ask you to come you can actually
like generally this we'll see the
dynamic yeah we'll see how she looks at
you
but i i do get that i'm not the norm and
i do think for the most part a lot of
guys are not mature enough to be friends
with a lot of girls and a lot of girls
the same way a lot of girls are just as
honey as guys which is something that i
found out in my late years and they
don't tell you that when you
i don't think it's a thing of being
mature i just think it's knowing exactly
who you are and what you're about
i think if you can be with if you like
as you said you can be friends with her
and whatnot if you feel like you can do
that you can do it do it like me
personally
like i've got
i can probably say i've got like one
female friend that i'm not attracted to
and it's like yeah cool we're cool how
turn what would you rate her
like the thing she used to be a tomboy
and
like and stuff like that so it kind of
yeah it's like it's kind of um so what's
the rating i'll give it like
i'll give it a i'll give her a good six
jeez yeah i'll give her a can you be a
girl that's less than a six how that be
a girl that's less than a six uh
probably okay so
but but that's what i'm saying that me
i'm not attracted to her in it do you
get me i'm not trying to tell her so i
can be like yeah we're friends in it she
get me but if i was attracted to her if
i did think she's sexy and whatnot then
i wouldn't
i wouldn't be i wouldn't be friends with
her like that mm-hmm
because i feel like i look at my friend
as good looking the same way look as my
male friend is a good-looking person
obviously
pause one
two is obviously it's obviously a little
bit different
have you ever checked out her butt
oh it's not coming
we were kids when we met what i was
twenty-six now we made trouble you
haven't done that in the last year no
your girlfriend's watching okay
okay
moving on
so um
so the first thing when i'm like
listening to the red pill you learn
about is hypergamy
and
at first it really sounds like a girl
only cares about a guy's money but
there's more to it they call it money
muscles and game
so if a guy wants to improve his status
basically and like be more attractive to
women he either needs to get muscles he
needs to make money or need he needs to
learn game
and that's how he increases his value in
the market
um is there anything as a guy you think
i missed
um
no because money is definitely one of
them yeah my father literally gave me
that talk and that was a weird talk to
help with your father but that you
should definitely have with your future
sons
at some point that don't chase these
women
chase the bag and the women will come
that's facts
wow
me personally i think i think you need
at least two
yeah there's two of those things like
because uh
money obviously is that will pay your
bills but if you've got game and muscles
yeah you ain't got no money yet you can
use game and muscle to
get money but i'm trying to think is
there like a fourth one because i feel
like they i feel like it's one of those
ones where like
[Music]
once you think about it in more depth
like there is definitely well there's
work ethic too but that goes into money
you know ambition when girls say
ambition it's just it just means he can
provide for her later
there's money so yeah i think that three
is actually yeah i think they're all
kind of synonyms of those three well and
it goes back into that men have a duty
of performance
so men are expendable and success object
and objectified worse than women
because men are the ones that are
expendable as in if there's a war who's
fighting
who does all the hard jobs
see this is why i mess with you
this is why i mess with you paul
and at first yeah and at first when i
heard this i kind of was like ah that
doesn't sound nice but there's just a
percentage of men that one are invisible
to women
like we just do not see unless they are
successful
yeah and
if if um
and the in part of the red pill is that
women can't love the way that men love
so we will never understand what it's
like for a man to love because a man can
love a girl that is just like dead broke
doesn't really do much and like
he he
will probably
and i guess like men can love multiple
women at a time so maybe an
ex-girlfriend that he's had he still
like loves her in a certain way where
girls can only love one guy at a time
and a girl um
and if if a guy becomes a bum like she
marries a guy and he he just starts
doing nothing becomes an absolute bum
like most women will leave